let
I guess so that that is truez did I G to
say look at you okay it's uh 9:15
roughly uh give or take a few moments um
we're here today for the first part of
today's work to look and to work on it
as a subcommittee on HB
1517 that's a bill relative to the
Statewide education property tax
commonly known as swep and excess
revenue from games of chance and we have
uh representative Harrington here and
along with folks from the uh Dr uh
Revenue Administration so uh I'd like to
have uh represent Harrington f up first
and we can have you know a a work
session together on this um uh perhaps
the best thing to start this out
represent Harrington if you could give
us a brief overview of what the intent
the bill is yeah uh first of all let me
again apologize for missing the public
hearing I thought this was going
directly the ways and means but I guess
if it says anything about Statewide
education property tax it automatically
comes here um the inten of the bill is
pretty simple I think anybody who's um
been paying attention to what's going on
in New Hampshire or watches the six o00
news for example every night there's
more and more ads for casinos uh we just
saw in yesterday's paper a new casino
was just approved in Conway and we're
not talking you casinos of 20 or 30
years ago we're talking thousands of
well they call them historical horse
racing but they're effectively slot
machines uh the table Stakes are going
up to $50 now which is a big increase
from where it was back a few years ago
and like I say these are Big commercial
establishments and they have to be
associated with the charity but the
amount of gambling revenue is going to
be going way way up and my goal of the
Bill of this bill is to Simply say let's
not use the increase in gambling revenue
is an excuse to increase or grow
government because you can use the
example from the state of New Hampshire
back um some 10 12 years ago uh they had
put in gambling down there I think
everybody remembers all the ads on TV
for the casinos and there was actually I
hadn't gone but I've known people who
went and there were people lined up two
three four deep waiting in line just to
get to a blackjack table and the
revenues went way way up and then the
recession came and the revenues went
down along with you know other tax
revenues in the state and they ended up
putting in big new increases in taxes
because they had expanded a bunch of
programs with this new Revenue thinking
it was just going to come forever and
you know I know over the next few years
we're going to see this big increase in
revenues but it it will flatten out
because it eventually it'll get
saturated and you'll just be the demand
for gambling will be fulfilled it's not
insatiable so the problem is though we
establish new government programs they
generally don't do that they keep
growing and growing and then they they
justify their existence by finding more
reasons for them to grow and that causes
of course the need for more tax revenue
so the intent of this bill is to just
not allow that to happen um like I said
I thought it was going to go to ways and
means I'm not an expert on uh taxes uh
by any stretch of the imagination it
seemed to me that the Statewide property
tax was the uh education property tax
was the best one to go after because
everybody pays that one way or the other
on the property tax bill even if you
rent your landlords paying that for you
so decreasing that would save people
money um but I've also me talked to some
other people that are more knowledgeable
than I am and one of the other
suggestions was that you could use it
for something like paying down the state
retirement obligation which I which is
very very large I know we did some of
that last year but um uh that would also
help everybody because it makes the
credit ratings better and it saves the
cities and towns money and so forth so
that's just another possibility what I'm
trying to say here is the goal is to
make sure the new gambling revenues
aren't used to expand the government and
someone more knowledgeable than me on
the best way to do that I'd certainly be
more than willing to listen and sit down
with them so thank you that's about
it are there any questions that we may
have as a committee that uh represent
Harrington might be able to
answer yes represent cordelli thank you
thank you representative for coming in
this morning um just wondering where the
from that's online
12 I believe that was
uh that's what ALS I believe came up
with that number it wasn't mine is um um
that was put into the bill because it's
that was what with the present level was
I believe
so thank you H how does the Dr going to
how are they going to estimate the
amount that be that and the timing for
the revenues to go into the
weep is that a question for I think
that's better answered by them I mean
all I what I was trying to do was set a
time frame where I'm assuming since the
the revenue is coming in and we know
where it's coming from that giv a date
we should be able to say any revenues in
excess of the amount collected
previously would be put into this new
bucket and but I'll I'll I'll leave that
to the revenue folks who have know more
about it than I do so with that we do
have Dr here and I think a lot of the
issues were going to have regarding the
timing and and and this amount of money
along with the 6.6 million um so if
there no more questions of represent
Harrington let's invite up Dr to help us
out with some of the timing and all this
least
good morning members of the committee my
name is Keen M Wong tax policy Council
within New Hampshire Department of
Revenue um the department does not have
a position on this bill however um the
department did prepare a fiscal note and
uh upon preparing fiscal notes were
prepared to answer a few questions and
we did identify uh certain um concerns
in terms of um administering the uh uh
the bill uh as identified by the
questions from uh representative L that
um first off is the the timing um so one
of the issues that we've identified uh
let me just go down here from what we
does everybody have that n Department of
Revenue Administration fiscal note a
quick
guide okay that's what we might be
right some of the questions are internal
yes so the the the first thing that that
we we wanted we that we identify is the
the concern is that the bill doesn't
stipulate the the date range in terms of
the payment deposit into the ETF um so
uh it does say that okay the amounts
that's from the gambling uh Revenue goes
into the ETF and then anything in excess
of the $6.6 million is going to be used
to deduct against the uh the 363 million
uh swept warant
calculation however
um the the bill is not clear in terms of
um the date range in terms of uh when
when to from when to when that the
revenue would be considered the gambling
Revenue would be considered in terms of
the the math to calculate the uh to
deduct the $6.6 million um in addition
to that um we also uh we're not certain
as to at which stage the revenue
reporting uh for the gambling winnings
would be considered would it be at the
act for reporting level or or a cash
basis level um or would it be something
that would be identified To Us by State
Treasury or from uh gaming commission or
something like that it it it probably
would be more straightforward if they uh
did that amount is certified to us and
then we can just use that number and
deduct the $6.6 million or if it's
already deducted $6.6 million so
whichever it is and you can use that
number in straight to away take into the
account for the calculation for the swep
warrant um the other thing is also the
timing of when we would know that number
um
so I spoken to the uh to Bruce um our
Municipal uh you know the the person who
manages the uh the the uh the the tax
rate calculation for the uh Statewide
education property tax and um he
indicated that the probably the best
timing to let for us to know that number
would be in early September um so that
we can calculate start calculating the
um the
warrant is is that a better issue that
we allow Ways and Means to make than the
policy committee dealing with education
policy
um I guess in terms of the um the the
timing and and the date range of of the
revenues um I I I I I would assume the
ways it means or or maybe um the the
sponsor might have have an indication of
of when well he indicated he thought the
bill was going to go to ways and means
but here we have it right here where
we're talking about adequacy and
everything else yeah and I'm not certain
how the bills get um sort it out between
um um so I I I I can't answer that
question I'm sorry okay thank you are
there other questions from the committee
here for Revenue Administration yes
represent luno so thank you very much Mr
uh Mr chair and thank you very much for
joining us again um could you talk a
little bit about um the uh the larger
picture in terms of how how monies flow
uh from the various Revenue sources into
the education trust fund obviously the
swept is just one of those U components
but um Lottery funds um I think are are
dedicated Lottery funds in excess of of
administrative cost prizes things like
that and then and then revenues that
come from uh business taxes and others I
was wondering if you could sort of talk
about how all of that is done um in
general in general each each kind of a
revenue Source um within that particular
statute would have a distribution um
section in the statute that says okay
this particular Revenue um is there a
percentage of this Revenue that goes to
the education trust fund and then the
remainder will go to general fund um so
there is no I don't think there's one
standard um law that applies to all
revenues so you need you'll need to look
at each particular reeven Revenue source
to see how that's being allocated uh by
legislature uh when when they drafted
that the bill to say okay we want a
certain percentage to go to to the
education trust fund like U like for
meals and rooms tax for example the um
the motor vehicle rental revenue is 100%
Going to the education trust fund so
that is in within the musing rooms um
statute itself yeah so each each statute
will be different
yeah yes yes and so for for uh revenues
that let's say come from uh business
profits tax business Enterprise tax yes
those percentages are a little more
Dynamic maybe based on budget um years
and Ways and Means maybe or um it it was
but last year um there was a bill I
believe it was last session um where it
fix and now it slipped my mind I can't
can't remember the percentage rate but
they legislature had fixed the uh the
percentage that goes to the education
trust fund and the the remained going to
the ETF so it's now a fixed percentage
whereas in the past before that bill it
was very tied to the tax rate itself so
there's a there's a calculation that
ties to the tax rate and then from that
a certain percentage goes to the
education trust fund is C percentage
goes to the um to the general fund and
when the tax X rate changes the amount
goes to each of the funds changes so um
based on that so and and if you can look
back to the history of the U let's say
business profits tax rates um whenever
legislation would meet
and potentially each session there might
be a change in the in the tax rate to
the business profits tax so now um after
the last session uh legislature has
decided to okay let's fix the rate can't
remember the rate now might be 40% I
can't don't callot me oh just me right
now
yeah for the committee we were provided
a sheet regarding the education trust
fund and all those revenues that was
passed out I think several meetings back
it's a sheet that shows all these
revenues you can go from the business
profits tax business Enterprise tax
meals and room tobacco real estate Etc
write down the list there and see the
estimated revenues they coming in far as
out the
fy2 so that is available to
us so are there any other questions for
Revenue Administration right
now yes represent cordelli thank you
thank you for being here um so basically
what I understood you to be saying is
that
Dr would prefer to see an amount uh
certified to you by the treasury for the
excess over the 6.6 million and that
would um uh preferably happen in early
September for your calculations yes um
that would make it more straightforward
so that uh there's no question in uh as
to where we would get that uh where in
the accounts like is it the act or is it
the cash flow um we will get the the the
amount um and and which date range so if
we were to be informed okay this is the
number that we to we to use so that
would help make it more straightfor but
if if there's other methods you know as
long as there's a fixed and um and
known
um uh I guess um qualification for that
number we can do that too as long as
that's very clear to us okay yep thank
you yep and if we have this information
by September as you've
stated is that timing enough for for
districts to know or know what their
rates are going to be taxing so that
number we inform at least at least by
September one yeah um and then that will
go into the and then be receiving all
the information from from the
municipalities and then we would be
calculating the tax rate and that would
generate the warrant to go out to the
municipalities so all this will happen
before the issuance of the warrant yeah
further further questions from the
committee not seeing thank you very much
thank you yeah so committee we have this
work session on this bill
um I think where we are is that there's
a lot of issues to have to be resolved
but it's best resolved in Ways and
Means unless you're going to look at
intent
yes again I want to apologize because I
expected this was going to Ways and
Means and that we'd be working on an
amendment I like I said I'm not a tax
expert so I guess my goal would be to
get it two ways and means so I could sit
down with people over there and make an
amendment to the bill it's obviously
going to need some changes to fix it up
and uh that that was my goal I didn't I
didn't think it was going to come here
so um if that could be possible I I'll
certainly say that I'll be working with
the people in ways and means to come up
with an amendment that addresses the
concerns that not only raised here but
raised by uh the department as well just
to let you know okay thank you thank you
very
much uh any other discussion right here
Boni thank you Mr chair um my question
actually is too intent um so right now
100% of Lottery funds raised less costs
go into the education trust fund and if
that's the case uh aren't we we're
really reducing Revenue into the
educational trust fund that's going to
sources I don't have an answer to
that yeah that's why I think it needs to
be you know I don't have all those
figures in front of me right now so I
can't respond to that but and there our
committees that have that information
and are constantly thinking dollars and
cents whereas we are not we're talking
overall policy you know why we need the
sweat
so yes represent
leus it looks to me in reading this and
that they're making sure that we're
not reducing the amount that we've been
getting because what we got in 23 three
was the 6,600 th000 and so they're say
so it looks like what they're saying
is what comes in over that is what's
going to be used to help reduce the the
property tax the swept property
tax and that's why that 6.6 million is
in there
because that's what we've been getting
and so they're taking it's a way of
defining the excess because if you say
excess you have to Define it so they're
defining it as whatever is above what we
got in
23 representative
Damon thank you Mr chair good morning
everybody I'm troubled with doing
anything that uh addresses swept when
the court in November said swep was
unconstitutional so it doesn't make any
sense to me at all to deal with this in
this way and maybe the
sponsors remark that perhaps it should
be if one wants to address the revenue
from games of
chance in the way that he's saying but
he spoke about maybe it would go towards
paying down the retirement debt that
makes sense to
me f discussion represent cardelli yeah
it's not my understanding that the court
said that uh swept was unconstitutional
yeah I think that's
reaching further than the court
specified
perhaps thanks very much Mr chair um
actually I think the court did say that
the way that um that swept was currently
being um um uh administered is
unconstitutional and they called it an
unconstitutional tax so so I think
representative Damon's characterization
was spot on that but but the point I
really wanted to make I think is um
is when we're you know when we take a
look at at House Bill
1516 and it seeks to um uh
reduce uh revenue flowing into the
education trust fund through the
Statewide um through through swept uh
uh then um then you know you know you
take a look at that trust fund it's um
it's it's it's got to gener a certain
amount of cash to uh to fund public
schools to fund efas to fund building
Aid to fund uh special education Aid to
fund there may be some other items as
well but when we're when we're taking um
when we're
reducing uh re a supply revenue from One
Source in case of the swep it actually
puts greater Demand on um Revenue from
other sources such as business profits
tax business Enterprise tax rooms and
meals tax and and others and uh the um
the report that I think the chair held
up is uh is right out of the um the the
most recent cfer the comprehensive
annual financial report uh which is
something that um that that all of us
should uh should be getting because it
it it it does show where uh where the
money's come from but uh yeah we reduce
it in leftt it's got to be made up for
somewhere
else represent
leus can we just reassign this to Ways
and Means because the things that people
are saying and are concerned about does
not is not what the bill is actually
saying so I think there are enough of us
that don't understand how this bill
Works can we just have it reassigned you
know just whatever that term is they use
but send it to Ways and Means
reassign it to ways and means it's
pretty late to be vacating an early bill
um the early bill has to be out here
this week so there's another way of
getting it the way means put it on
consent and send the ways means it comes
back to the the floor for a vote uh how
you'd have to be very careful in how you
wrote your committee report up with the
intent of why we'd like to see it go
there uh there's a bigger picture to
this whole thing right now with the
education trust and that's something
that this policy committee ought to be
aware of I'm not looking at that Revenue
sheet right now but if you look at the
figure in the bottom right hand column
on the very
bottom total revenues there are what 222
million dollar as I
recall in in the
fund now that money which is not used
would then there's an effort to put it
back into the general fund and use that
money to support other aspects of
running this
state
now there one can read pluses to that or
in one can read minuses but I think each
one of you need to be considering where
we're going in terms of some of the
issues that are affecting education
we're trying to figure out how to
support catastrophic Aid We're trying to
support figure out how to support
building Aid we're trying to figure out
how to support adequacy all these things
are going on right now uh we we just
passed a bill not too long ago on a 12
to8 vat which dealt with uh providing
meal plans for breakfast or lunch which
is a costway program I think that zeroed
in somewhere between $4 and $50 million
where's that money going to come from
right so there there are a lot of policy
considerations that have to be looked at
in terms of of the bigger picture uh
where are we going with the education
trust fund
and and this one right here I don't
think this committee is
really qualified right now to make some
of these decisions regarding we're
qualified yes but uh from a policy
perspective but our job is also to try
and figure out where the revenues are
coming from and how that it meshes out
with everything else that we're using
revenues for to run the state and that
is the job of ways and means um so uh I
kind of agree with represent that
because I like to get this thing over
the way of means somehow and and U try
to write in some kind of a committee
report that you know we don't really
take a position on this we just want to
get this thing out and get a better idea
of the impacts to it graan
luno thanks very much Mr chair you know
the I I I don't know why we feel like or
why why there may be such a why we're in
a rush to get this over to ways and
means I don't know why the games of
chance under 287 D20 are necessarily any
different than any other than any other
Revenue sources that may go up or down
in any in any given year uh certainly
the prime sponsor could file this bill
again and uh and then maybe it would be
rooted routed um more directly over to
ways and means but I certainly don't
don't see that that we should
necessarily consider this particular
Revenue Source
um which is
in the grand scheme of of Lottery uh as
being something that that then offsets
uh another Revenue Source frankly I
don't know how the watery commission be
able to consider to be able to say every
dollar goes to uh goes to schools if
it's all of a sudden taking away a
dollar from from somewhere else so so I
I really don't see any reason to uh to
FastTrack this to uh to ways of me means
um um it doesn't appear that that the um
that the that the amount is going to be
terribly large uh but uh but that the
impact I think on on other Revenue
sources down the road uh would uh would
not be good and um and you know I I I
think we could just take care of it
right here represent cordelli did you
yeah I would just say that I I think
that the goal is to apply
the excess over 6.6 million and let um
let the treasury work that out um as
suggested by Dr um that that be applied
to swep to reduce local property taxes
local local school taxes um that would
come straight off the the state line on
our tax statement um for any amount uh
in in excess that was applied um I think
that's a a worthy goal and something
that um we should look at and um get
over to Dr and I would be all in favor
of I'm sorry yes Ways and Means um
getting ahead of myself um uh check with
the um maybe the speaker's office and
see if um we could vacate it to stay
within the time frames of reporting by
the
15th that we can check yes we can check
that out represent Miler U thank you Mr
chairman you know I I may be uh way out
in left field here I don't know but uh I
recall when Governor Hassen was the
governor and she was pushing gaming big
time I was against it then and I'm
against it now and uh I just I just I
I'm concerned you know as I see these
ads on TV I I when I saw these ads on TV
about gambling here and gambling there
I'm saying where the hell this come from
oh this is Charity game gaming right
charity gaming right 35% supposed to go
to local charities there's a heck of a
lot of money going to those who own this
gaming
establishment and uh I I frankly I'm I'm
opposed to gambling I'm opposed to this
bill and I may be way out there but I'm
going to stick by my guns I was against
it when Governor hasson did it I'm
against it now I don't like to see the
ads on TV and I think this is is a an
kind of an IFC come uh source of
Revenue uh and I I'm just opposed to the
concept alog together and we've never
had a gaming bill that we've decided in
this committee it's gone elsewhere to
other committees thank you so that
that's we have we have not acted on any
that's been ever since I've been in the
house we've had gaming bills coming up
and and uh the house has never been
supportive of that whereas the Senate
May is maybe uh so it's repesent
leus is Ways and Means the second
committee that this would go to I I
don't know that's a decision that's made
by because I was just thinking if that
was the second committee then all we're
doing by vacating it is moving it to
them a week early because they would be
getting it and be under the second
committee time but maybe not but that's
what I was
thinking to do that
but this doesn't stop this bill doesn't
stop charitable gaming the money's
coming in now the excess money would
still be going
into the education trust fund because
this doesn't change that
law all this says is if there is extra
it goes to help offset property tax yeah
so where we are right now is we're going
to have the debate on this tomorrow it's
up for executing tomorrow it's an early
early bill that's why we do have a rush
on the bill um and we you know had the
really the bill presented to us uh by
the representative that brought forward
today and that's the first time I've
really even dealt with this thing and of
course on top of the all the 23 early
bills we've had and the 49 other bills
that have fiscal notes attached to them
it's it's been a very burdens and type
uh last several months so um if we have
nothing else say on this right now I
will go forward and see if it can be
vacated but I doubt that that's going to
be the case seeing that we have
possession of it and there's only you
know it's got to be acted on by the
house floor or submitted for Action by
the 15th and so we're in that week so Mr
chair yes um another and I think it's
good to check on on whether whether this
could be vacated uh but um but you know
just a just another comment on this as a
policy as we the the way the funding
formula works and correct me if I'm
wrong is that is that is that the state
adequacy Grant the direct state adequacy
grants um get paid um directly
to
municipalities uh after the swept has
been collected so that when less swept
is collected there will be for whatever
that that difference is less that will
be additional
State funds that come from the education
trust fund to make up for that
difference so if we short the swept by
say I mean just which we've done before
but by $100 million right right if by so
just like what we what what happened
three years ago if you short the swept
by $100 million it means two things it
means $100 million needs to come in to
the education trust fund to make it for
that different difference and another
100 million has to come in because
you've got increased direct adequacy
grants that need to be made for those
communities that are now paying that are
now um uh raising Less in sweat towards
their adequacy amount it it's a double
it's a double Guta represent cordelli
thank you and three years ago when we
did the reduction um of $100 million in
Swat
um we did take money uh from um Surplus
I believe to um compensate for that so
that there was no shortfall in the
education trust fund by $100 million um
so that that difference was made up and
I think we're talking about um an amount
in excess of the 6.6 which um you know I
I think again Ways and Means would have
a better handle on if that's the right
number or
not6 we don't know what that is but uh
if that is what we have been getting
into the education trust fund from uh
the lottery uh from all sorts of gaming
um then uh I don't see a problem because
anything in the future um with possibly
more uh gaming and and I understand the
opposition to gaming um but it would
just be additional revenues we see in
the future uh over and above what we're
getting now that would go to reduce the
swept in the property
tax okay so we're gonna close this work
session down right now because we've
gone beyond our time but we will pick
this up tomorrow during the exact
session so we take about a four or five
minute break right now and then we're
gonna CAU us pardon me were we going to
CAU us now or did you want to talk yeah
well that's what we're going to take the
break and then we're going to go talk
y um basically you don't have to put it
out yet because we want to go talk of
them then come back and then we'll put
okay
party caucus for a few moments here and
we will probably be back in about 20 20
minutes so approximately by that clock
around quarter after
thereabouts the hour excuse me I'm
looking now it's a shadow on it um so
we'll be coming back here probably
around
earlier I don't think they know they're
not supposed to so so during caucus all
people are not on the committee need to
room you
12:45
B I got find my
amendments
yeah
I want to remind committee members that
if you make a motion that the motion uh
you have to write the committee report
and we'd like to have those committee
reports done as quickly as possible
today so with that let's get into the
business of the first bill which we're
going to take up and we will we'll go
down in a sequential order but we're
going to jump over a few
bills uh and then come back I okay the
first bill we're taking up is HB
1109 requiring relative requiring
student identification cards to include
the helpl line for the National Alliance
for eating disorders we have a motion
that was made at the previous
meeting and I can't tell you the date
that occurred on but the motion was itl
and I'd like to ask the person who made
that motion represent dry did you make
that motion
yes I did I it would you please pull the
motion yes I will resend that okay and
the second was made by represent beler
agreed okay so now we're we have no
motion on the floor and I'm going to
look to representative Pell for a
motion thank you I move OTP on House
Bill 1109 repon Damon thank you very
much we'd like to speak to your
motion yes thank you um I would actually
amendment
okay that's um
H 11 okay let's make sure everybody has
that that's
problem get so much pie held up
here
number
H this representative Damon seconding
the yeah represent Damon that's
motion I've read it go ahead I can find
it's under this yeah pile somewhere here
so we can go ahead and discuss the
amendment the bill is amendment are are
you are you is there a motion on the
amendment yes yes I move ought to pass
as amend with the am with I move ought
to pass with Amendment 0403 H and
represent Daman your second the
amendment thank you would you like to
speak to your motion please yes thank
you
um this this bill as the whole was
brought forward again this year after
issues were found last year with the
organization that was to be listed on
the back of the um student ID cards and
this is related to
um eating disorders and awareness
building awareness in high school
students of eating disorders and this
year the it was when it was brought
forward the number is for the National
Alliance for eating disorders and we
have been assured that this organization
is well vetted and has been around for
long enough that we can be assured that
they won't have issues with their card
and they plan on extending the hours
that they are available to take live
calls but as we were working on the bill
and looking up um looking up the laws we
noticed that the um Suicide Hotline That
was supposed to be on the back of ID
cards also needed to be update and so we
brought forth this amendment to update
the um title of the suicide the 988
suicide in crisis lifeline and so that's
that's what this bill does it puts two
numbers on the back of the ID cards
thank you represent Amon do you have any
further
discussion Echo all of what
representative peternell said and just
to be
clear the amendment adds to the original
Bill language so the bill language
regarding the National Alliance foring
service hel line is exactly the same and
then just adds this section to update
the correct title of what was the
National Suicide Prevention and is now
the 988 suicide and crisis Lifeline so
students will have access to both
numbers and can use what is relevant to
their particular needs thank you is
there any further discussion from the
committee yes represent
leus I just want to commend rep Damon
and rep Pell for what I understand was a
complicated process to do
what looks like a simple thing I guess
it was very complicated so thank you
very much represent Cordell thank you Mr
chair um I guess I want to second that
what representative Lua said because as
you all both are all know I was very
much against the original bill due to
the lack of 247 coverage and some other
issues uh you all know that but I feel
like this is a great example of um doing
what's best for the kids and getting
this uh the the language changed here
and an updated Suicide Hotline I don't
think it's perfect I'm still concerned
about this organization they say they're
going to go 24 you know increase their
hours I hope they abide by that um but I
will be voting for this amendment and
the Bill thank you further discussion
represented Ry thank you very much this
is not a hill I want to die on um but um
I just want to reiterate that the the
still the trend is to go to 988 it's to
go to three-digit numbers to make it
easy here's the emergency numbers in
Sullivan County that could all go easily
on the back of an ID because they're all
important um and we're moving towards
the easiest way to get there you get a
real person
247 on the 988 hotline at this point and
that's what I feel is important I
understand where you are all coming from
but this is what I feel is important
thank you thank you further discussion
not seeing any uh Madam clerk would you
please call the rule on the amendment is
04038 vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
Donald yes representative Noble yes
representative Pell yes representative
corello yes representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
Luna yes Representative Keith yes
representative wock yes representative
Hall yes representative Bon yes
representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes thank you and
chairman lad yes 28 z
a representative Pell recognize for a
motion
otpa I'd like to move otpa on House Bill
119 as amended and represent Damon thank
you so we have a motion on the table now
is to amend uh
1109 with 0403 h that's the amendment
further discussion from either of those
represent Perell or represent Amon no
any further discussion from the
committee Madam clerk when you're ready
nice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry no representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Pell yes representative
corello yes representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
Luna yes representative Heath yes
representative wock yes representative
Hall yes representative Bon yes
representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad
yes 19 y one nay any problem with
consent no Minority Report no no no no
no okay
so so we are good with 1109 let's hustle
down to
the next one which is HB
1185 this is relative to sexual
education instruction I Look to
representative cordelli for a motion uh
thank you Mr chairman I would like to
move inter room
study is there a second to that motion
second so we have we have a motion on
the table to inter room
study 1185 made by representative
cordelli and second by representative
Miler further discussion from either
just briefly if I might um I uh support
the uh goals of the sponsors of this
bill um I I think that there are issues
with some of the uh
wording um and possibly even the uh
section of Statute uh to which it's
proposed um so therefore um my uh
interum study
motion further
discussion any further discussion from
the committee so we have a motion on the
table right now for interim study for
1185 Madam clerk when you're
ready Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative peternell yes
representative Coro yes representative
Miler yes representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno representative Heath yes
representative wot yes representative
Hall yes representative Boni yes
representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad
yes 28 Z knes so any problem consent
they'll put that in consent thank you
very much next bill we're going to
address is 1235 this is a bill relative
high school students serving as school
board members I'd like to uh recognize
represent cascaden for a motion thank
you Mr chair I move to OTP this bill is
there a
second I'd like to introduce okay the
motion has been made by representative
cascaden and second by representative
peternell as OTP represent cascad I'd
like to introduce uh an amendment it's
number
H is there a
second represent second okay motion made
by for seconding from our motion made by
uh represent cascaden for
0646 H and second by representative Pell
representative cascaden do you like to
speak to your motion yes to um the bill
that was presented initially had some
language added uh in line 789 pertaining
to how the members were selected would
strike all of that in the amendment
there's no need for it keep the original
um law and the only change would be uh
in the requirement in line 16 uh
attending all school board meetings just
taking the word all so that it said it
reads as original attending school board
meetings and then strike the Bold that
came in after that so it just removes
all and districts can decide which
school board meetings they need to
attend they can attend them all or they
can attend just some so it's just one
Amendment one word Amendment I'm
sorry representative Pell do you have
any further discussion no thank you
further discussion from the
committee not seeing any further
discussion from the committee madam clar
we have a motion on the table it's a uh
Amendment uh
0646 h on
1235 HP
1235 Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative
peternell yes representative Corell yes
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative Luna yes representative
Heath yes representative wock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Alon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes and chairman
lad yes 20a Zer n so put that one also
on consent any objections that was the
amendment well excuse me I'm trying to
rush through this thing
so would you
plee representa cascaden would you like
to make a motion of
1235 represent Fel so the Motions made
to
otpa uh this house of this bill with
0646 h as the amendment made by
representative cascaden and second by
representative peternell further
discussion Madam clerk Vice chairman
cordelli yes representative leus yes
representative Ford yes representative
elure yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative Corell yes
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative luno yes representative
Heath yes representative wock yes
representative Hall yes representative
albone yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad
yes 20 y Zer so we'll put that one on
consent and it's good to get rid of the
double standard where elected board
members don't have to attend all
meetings but students do yeah it's like
okay
right okay so good job uh going down to
the next bill which we have on the
docket that we're jumping a couple here
is HB
1356 this is relative to the use of
children's names and pronouns by Public
School Employees a look to
representative uh leus to for a
motion I move to itl hb13 1856 is there
a
second who who made that
one did represent Damon make that motion
I think she okay represent Damon makes
the motion
so okay motion made by itl by represent
leus and second by representative Damon
our representative leus would you like
to speak to your motion yes um I think
this bill
was not written right and the biggest
thing that jumped out at me before I
even got very far down reading it was
well partly just given names and knowing
that some kids never liked their given
names and never went by them in school
and the other part is just nicknames in
general whether it's sports teams or
whatever nicknames are an important part
of acceptance to a kid you get a
nickname it means you know you're known
you're you're recognized whatever and so
the idea that we can't give kids
nicknames without parental permission is
just
wrong represent represent
Amon what she
said we're on the same page there okay
further discussion from the committee
the motion is to
itl uh the bill which is
1356 and motion was made by represent
lakas and second by represent Damon so
no further discussion Madam clerk would
you please call the RO the motion is
itl vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Ford yes representative beler yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Pell yes representative
Corell yes representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
Luna yes representative Heath yes
representative wock yes representative
Hall yes representative Bon yes
representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes and chairman
um as a prior teacher myself as a prior
principal later uh administrator outside
the state um the it's the responsibility
and I'll take kindergarten for example
and I've said this before in committee
everything a kid should know is learned
and taught in kindergarten
and that means having to work together
collaborate together respect the other
person that's coming in and out of the
door uh and that's all social
interaction and so I I believe that
there's this this bill is uh uh there
got a lot of stuff in it and when it's
in indicating to a teacher you got to be
very careful in terms of uh in teaching
these social skills which are
extremely important to listen when the
teacher is talking you don't sit there
you know gabbing with a friend uh that's
a social skill and it's also a necessary
skill in in order to learn so this is
why I'm opposing uh and the the passage
of this bill it's it's a skill that's
necessary the social experiences in
athletics and is extremely important
there's a lot to it thank you very
much representer yes thank you uh
chairman cordelli uh I think in the in
the um 12 years I've been on this
committee that this hearing um was
probably the they had the broadest
breath of individuals that came before
us I mean we had Corrections people we
had social workers we had counselors we
had teachers we had parents and I think
this was a very telling uh hearing that
really talked about the breath of the
need for to deal with kids social
emotional learning and also I think the
issue too that when we talk about
businesses one of the things that the
business people say that we need to have
people who can communicate with one
another who can deal with one another so
I I I totally agree with the itl on this
motion thank
you thank you any further comments from
the
committee I seen
none thank you mad Madam clerk thanks
chairman cordelli yes representative
leus yes representative Ford yes
dry
yes representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative Corell yes
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative luno yes representative
Heath yes representative wock
representative Hall yes representative
bbon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad
yes 19 y one
nay consent yeah okay so I'll take the C
back yeah okay moving on down now to the
next bill which is HB
1496 relative the state's duty to
protect children in public
schools representative my you recognized
for our motion I moved it please I'll
second
it we're slowing down a little bit here
we're getting ahead of our clerk no it's
1496 okay we have a motion on the table
it's to itl 1496 the motion's made by
represent Miler and second by
representative lad representative Miler
you're recognized yes I think I think
this is uh again is a there's no
question in our minds that that students
need to be protected and I believe that
currently that uh schools have done uh a
great job in uh making that available
particularly in the environment that we
have across the country and within this
state to make sure that students do have
the benefit of going to school and
parents have the benefit of that they're
going to be safe so I don't think this
is necessary thank you
and as making the of the seven the
second here uh on line five the bill
there's mentioned to local parentice in
this bill and I think it's extremely
important that um we don't have it
anywhere else in statute and school
districts years and years ago had this
terminology in and we got into real
problem areas with it I think it's best
that local Apprentice not be put into
statutory
language further discussion on the bill
representative beler thank you Mr chair
I just wanted to add to what um you
commented on that I I think I understand
the underlining intent of the bill and I
think it's a good intent but the
possibility has been raised that by
adding in local parenes to the bill
we're not sure if we're actually
expanding the scope of requirement and
possible uh interventions on the part of
the school so I think the safest thing
to do is itl and uh maybe we'll see this
again with different language in the
future
committee okay we have a a motion that's
been put forth by represent Miler second
by represent lad it's itl in
1496 any further discussion on I'm part
of the committee not seeing any Madam
clerk would you please call the role V
chairman cordelli yes representative
leus yes representative Ford yes
representative beler yes representative
dry yes representative Donal yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative Coro yes
representative Miler representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative Luna yes representative
Heath yes representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
albon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad
yes 20 y zero
n consent yes thank
you uh going on down to the next bill
which we're going to address this
morning is HB
1643 this is requiring school districts
to make curriculum and instructional
materials available on their web pages
to represent Miler makes the motion itl
and I will second
that represent miler
I think it's already being done so I
don't think many will say anything more
thank you I'm of the same position any
further
discussion Madam clerk will you please
call the role the motion is itl on on
1643 motion was made by represent Miler
and second by represent
lad Vice chairman Celli yes
representative leus yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher no
representative dry yes representative
McDonald
no representative Noble yes
representative
Pell yes representative Cora yes
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative Luna yes representative
Heath yes representative wock yes
representative Hall yes representative
alboni yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad
yes 18 y to n any objections to
consent okay we'll put that on consent I
excuse yes on
consent is there a Minority Report no
not unon okay going down to the last one
on the bottom of the list right here
1692 this is relative to high school
graduation
requirements
you want to hand the G yeah I hand the G
over this is House Bill
1692 and I call on chairman lad for a
motion like to make a motion of itl
second second by representative Miler
um anything uh to comment uh I'm trying
okay this bill is addressing to the
requirement of a of an
assessment for
graduation and
um the in the high school the Statewide
assessment would be the SAT and that's
given in the 11th grade I don't think
that's a proper assessment of the
curriculum maybe that's provided in that
particular School even though it's one
we use uh in the 11th grade so um I I
think there's multiple ways of De
determining uh a student being competent
in these areas and I don't think it's
necessarily done through a singular
test represent Miler I
did thank you um anything further from
the
committee uh seen yes representative
Lakers I see I just wanted to say that I
think think this could be done through
like the GED or the highet or something
but there is nothing in here specifying
what it is well there is but what as
representative L as chairman lad
said it's the SAT and I think that is
not at all the appropriate test thank
you that's it thank you anything further
seen nothing Madam
Clerk
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Pell yes representative
Coro yes representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative tenner yes representative
Luna representative Heath yes
representative
wock yes representative Hall yes
representative Balon
yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad
yes 20 a
z any uh objections to consent we're all
there
yep okay that takes us
down the list here so
it okay so we just we just took care of
1 two 3 four five six seven eight
bills still catching
up okay so we're just let's take a let's
take a short break uh let's take a a f
minute break here so the clerk can catch
up okay I've only got the one eorder one
with I gota go back to that well just
yeah don't get all your paperwork mixed
up good got to dot the te dot the teeth
and cross the eyes you know what I mean
that's right you need five
minutes well we're going to work down
through things here let me uh so we'll
be looking at it be easier for you
actually it's easier for me when it's
harder for yes exactly because I have
time
to we got to do them all so we might as
them
which we're going to take up and we're
1437 this is relative to the membership
of the State Board of
Education
here so I Look to representative Belcher
for a motion thank you Mr chair I would
move itl is there a
second second so we have a motion made
by represent Belcher
uh as itl and second by represent
Belcher yes thank you Mr chair so what
this bill seeks to do is it it expands
the Board of Education in the state from
Seven members to 11 um and it designates
uh that the new positions will be filled
primarily by those who are um
Professionals in the field of Education
or Administration now we've heard
testimony um that from the Board of
Education that this really this this
bill would flip the historical intent of
the board of education on its head where
the board was originally founded to be a
a facet of our government of by and for
the people run by a civilian um
nonprofessional oversight um by putting
these positions in there it would really
move it toward a more administrative
model it would put put people in the
position of regulating their own fields
that they're um actively employed in
which is generally not considered the
best practice from fields to
Pharmaceuticals to finance and Beyond um
as it creates incentives uh that could
be not great um in terms of
self-regulation like that um so it would
create a moral hazard in that effect
thank you thank you very much from the
second is is there discussion nothing
further further discussion the motion is
itl represent
leus then represent Tanner yes um Edna
is currently going through all of the
various boards and certifications and
whatever to try to do away with any
places where you have the people
regulating themselves because they have
found problems with that through the
years and they have been going through
to make them independent or advisory
only Etc and so this sort of goes
backwards from what we're trying to do
in all in across the state in all the
other
areas thank you represent
Tanner um thank you uh this is my bill
and I do have an amendment that changes
it um which I would offer if it if we
get a chance but um whenever you have a
board like this that is making decisions
like they're going to actually make a
decision on the 306 standards they um
have become the the the board that uh
makes a ton of decisions uh affecting
education in the state and yet no one on
the on the board has any education
background or at least is not um versed
in that and I find that very difficult
uh I'm sure on the the um AMA they have
a few doctors uh retired doctors or
people that have been in in the medical
field um you know just because you're uh
Ride On A Plane uh you don't become a
pilot and um you know I think people
sometimes uh use the idea that they've
gone to school for the 12 years um of
schooling and then post-graduate or post
yeah postsecondary education
post-graduate education um that they
know what is happening in classrooms and
teachers uh and our public education
across the state and I think in the
recent years the reason I brought this
forward is I've been
seeing uh a lot of misunderstandings
coming from that state board level and I
I think that it needs to be expanded
certainly we have a lot more on their
plate than they did in uh 1919 when it
was formed uh you know we we've expanded
uh um our population our population of
uh children to educate and um I just
feel that it it's necessary to have this
discussion um about the state board and
I think it's a shame uh really to have
to look at boards and try to filter out
anybody that might have any expertise in
that field thank you represent McDonald
thank you Mr chair I'm not going to
speak to the qualifications of the board
memb
as listed in statute or in the bill or
amended I'm more concerned about the
fact that we are expanding the number of
members on the board and it seems to me
to be an expansion of government that is
unwarranted have we heard testimony that
more members should be on this board and
what purpose that serves to me it's
deeply concerning with those questions
unanswered so I will not be supporting
the Bill thank you represent Cornell I I
think I was most concerned about the
lack of an application process when the
chair of the board was asked how do
people get put on the board or what is
the application process he I think he
said I don't know I got a call out of
the blue asking me if I wanted to be on
it so I said yes and to me that's a
little bit concerning that there isn't
any method of choosing the people that
are on it if you can get a call out of
the blue and say do you want to be on
this board and you say oh yeah sure that
that's concerning to
me representative
wood thank you chairman L um I just want
to follow up a moment if I may on uh
representative Tanner's comments the
same ilk here when I look around this
particular board that we're sitting in
right here now and we try to establish
policy and how many times that people on
this board said I was a teacher I was an
administrator and I bring this to the
board and others who are not there who
are not teachers early balance it out so
we have a wider perspective what we're
saying here is we don't want that wider
perspective I I think we need to have uh
and and the folks around this table who
have backgrounds and education who have
taught always bring a different
perspective than those that haven't and
that's how we get a balance of good
policy I think this the board definitely
needs to have some professional balance
on here I would I would follow uh as
representative Tana has said that it's
probably imperative of this board
particularly with the rural State
education thank you chairman lad further
discussion representative Damon and then
represent
dry thank you Mr chair I'm opposed to
the itl I think in
any area of knowledge there are people
who are educated and have
expertise that we should want to have
participate in decision making I
wouldn't want the Department of
Environmental services to pass
regulations for septic design without
folks who have expertise in septic
systems to provide input to that I would
not want a pharmacy board or the FDA
process for approving meds not to
involve the folks who know the most
about pharmaceutical studies I think
it's a frankly absurd idea that we
wouldn't involve educated trained
education professionals on the board of
education represent dry thank you for uh
Mr chairman I the governor and Council
appoint the members of the board that
means there is some vetting going on it
has to go through the governor and
council meeting and uh just like a judge
or any other appointment so I'm thinking
there is more than just answering a
phone
call represent uh cordelli thank you Mr
chairman um just in terms of uh the uh
selection of members um having been a
member of heak home education advisory
Council and the uh special education
advisory Council um I have recommended
people for both of those um
organizations um myself um uh some go
through through to the governor's office
my
recommendations um he act um just goes
through if there's an opening to the
speaker's office um but I remember also
there was a period in time with uh uh
the special education advisory Council
when leadership of that Council was
requiring prospective members to come in
and be interviewed by the council which
I strongly objected to um you know
filtering
applicants by the the council themselves
so I I think that the uh current process
uh works well and as representative dry
said it all goes through the governor
and the executive counsel that's why we
have an executive Council thank
you represent
chair okay I'm going to put the elephant
in the room
here Mr it wise has come
forward in the
past the board of educ state board of
education has had a very balanced
approach to looking at
issues you've had people who've been
conservative you had people who've been
liberal unfortunately at this point in
time because of the current leadership
in the
state we have an ultraconservative State
Board of
Education with no
balance that's my concern no
balance and I think the this has been I
don't know the motive behind
representative
Tanner's uh Amendment
here but I think it represents a
need for the Department of Education the
State Board of Education to have a more
balanced look at what's happening in
education and the decision-making
process that needs to take place and I'm
not talking about having a liberal board
or or a total conservative board I'm
talking about a
balance and in the past there has been a
balance on that
board there is no balance on the board
as it sits right now based upon the
decision making that they
have we have the 306s that are coming up
major issue that's going to direct
public education in this
state and I have a great deal of fear of
what's going to come out of that state
board based upon the particular
persuasion political persuasion they
have right now now we do have thanks to
Chairman lad thank you we've had we
passed uh 1673 early in this session
that talks about an oversight of those
rules so that that kind of neutrals my
sense a little bit because there'll be
some legislative oversight to the
decision that's going to take place
but I think the motive behind the
expanding this we didn't need this
before because there was a balanced
approach and I think this bill at least
provides some sense of people who've had
some experience because we have no one
in there that really has the experience
now and I think that's a deficit to the
decision-making process that directs
public education thank you Mr chair okay
I'd like to take an opportunity to speak
to this too
because I don't believe we need this
now and for for numerous
reasons we're saying that no one on the
State Board of Education has the
understanding the knowledge the
experience and education I don't think
that's
so and I don't think it's so that you
have to be working in a school to have
that experience and that wisdom I also
look at the bill as it was introduced
us and as it is being submitted
elsewhere where it
says there shall not be professionally
the person that we have there on the
board shall not be engaged in school
work Educators or professionally engaged
in school work I wonder why that was put
into law years ago we don't have the
superintendent of school sitting on the
school board at the local school
district is there a reason for that of
course there's a reason for
it and there's a reason why we shouldn't
have a superintendent school sitting on
the State Board of Education
too the superintendent of schools is's
going to come in with a lot of ownership
on topics and engaged in certain
organizations which you're going to now
be doing the lobbying from the
inside I don't think that's right I
think this is a citizen legislature we
need to have a citizen board
running our schools state board and
that's appointed by governor and counsel
and our forefathers had the wisdom to
check the balance of the governor
through a
councel and so we have these checks and
balances in place the people have to be
approved by governor and
councel and there the governor and
councel are elected by the residents of
this state so it's refle reflecting
where we are at that moment in time it
may not be like it is for as we see it
right now 10 years from now it could go
the opposite side that's okay one year
from now that that's the way democracy
works and I I think it's a dreadful err
that we people put people on the State
Board who are professionally
engaged in the business of Education
where they're making their welfare and
their income from that and they're also
going to be the ones that are deciding
on issues of professionalism on the part
of a teacher when that comes up for
appeal and action by the state board or
other issues uh so uh I'm I I'd be
really cautious before moving this this
bill forward it seems to me that we're
we could be putting people into the
State Board who really have conflicts of
interest thank you representa cordelli
thank you following on to that one of
the duties of the State Board is to hear
a appeals Whenever there is dispute
between um a parent and a local school
board that's in statute now so if we
have um people on there who uh are not
citizen um members of the board but
professional Educators it might swing
the balance in terms of hearing those
appeals would there be Rec recusals
necessary so I think that um that's one
area where uh I can see a problem if we
uh move forward with this
legislation represent
leus our local school boards are elected
locally by the
citizens this is
like the state level of that so to
individually elect those by the all the
people would be unwieldy so instead the
citizens elect the governor and the
executive board and we have had times
when those were very divided and the
governor voted one way or recommended
and the counselors um voted against him
depending upon they are representing the
makeup of the citizens and the will of
the citizens at that time that's what
this government is set up for it's a
representative
democracy and this is furthering that
rep representative democracy
the representatives are the counselors
in this case and they're voting the will
of the people who elected them there
have been times when it was solidly in
one party now it's solidly in another
party but that goes back and forth
depending upon the will of the people
very often it's mixed because very often
in New Hampshire we have a mix so it's
representing the will of the people
which is the point of the school board
it's the appoint of the local school
board and this is just the Statewide
school board and it needs to be made up
and elected the same way in effect as
our local school boards and represent
the citizens of the state representa
Tanner thank you um first of all I'd
like to say that all the surrounding
states uh have Representatives on their
on their school boards of even uh
teachers unions uh aft uh Nea they have
uh superintendents they have teachers um
so it's not we're not trying to break uh
like the national Trend or anything like
that the original school board was also
meant uh another F phrase in there that
came out was that it was supposed to be
uh bipartisan and they had actually a
requirement in the initial uh Charter
that no more than three people of one
party could be on the on on the uh
School Board of five so they were they
were very um conscious of having it
become too political which it has um my
Amendment takes out the the professional
teachers um uh I think it also adds a
student uh representative on the board
which I think is really really important
I think also uh my bill uh speaks to the
number of terms and the and the years of
terms uh and I think that people that um
are appointed uh and we're not sure how
they actually get to that position uh
could be there for many many many years
with the with the four consecutive terms
and three-year terms that's a long time
to have somebody in so it's not a not a
flip that happens on a regular basis um
I'd like to have the opportunity to put
forward the amendment um so um that's my
little spe brother discussion on the
part of the committee represent Damon Mr
chair I have a procedural question um as
still the Newbie is there any way for an
amendment to be put forward when the
OTP the itl has to be voted down and OT
has to be brought forward in order to
have an amendment move forward unless
you take it right to the house floor
that's what I thought thank you can we
however have that Amendment passed out
and look at it not it's we've got it
well then
okay
itop
copy I only have one
copy got you need more copies down there
yeah none of us got them
oh there they are
are
yeah okay the motion on the floor right
now is
itl is there any more discussion on the
itl not seeing Madam clerk would you
please call the
rle can we take a moment to
read we're in the voting
mode is Chairman cordelli yes
representative leus yes representative
Ford yes representative beler yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative peternell yes
representative Coro yes representative
miler no representative Cornell no
representative Tanner no Representative
luno no representative Heath no
Representative wock no representative
Hall representative bon no
Representative cascaden no
representative Damon no chairman lad yes
10 y 10
NS put a bill or a motion make a motion
please yes there a motion here like to
move um OTP on
14337 so there's a motion for on 1437
OTP made by representative Tanner second
by representative Miler representative
Tanner you recognize yes um I'd like to
have this um Bill considered and uh the
amendment that that I'd like to put
forward are you putting forward the
amendment oh yes I'd like to uh put
forward Amendment
0648 H to my bill um and speak to it if
I
can okay we have an amendment that's
been put forward 0
648h by represent Tanner and second by
represent
Miler got
that represent Tanner so my Amendment um
speaks to uh in section three that the
governor with the consent of the
executive Council shall appoint the
members of the board um and the five
members shall be selected one each from
five executive council districts which
is as it is right now so those are
people from the community um two members
shall be selected from the public at
large so you have seven members on an 11
member board that are community members
in addition to that I have one retired
public school classroom teacher one
parent of a current excuse me is that a
retired I says one public school
classroom teacher
retire pardon me okay I'm looking at the
wrong sorry apologize
ol one parent of a Current public school
student which I think a parent um is
really important and then one member of
the New Hampshire school administrators
Association and lastly one student who's
serving on a public school board and
representing as a non- voting member
shall be selected so I think this
balances out the board it gives um at
least some uh input from people who are
currently working with schools or have
uh recently working with schools and I
would hope that that retired teacher
might be the teacher of the year but um
I would kind of gave that up um and um I
think having a student and a parent on
the board is is going to offer a lot of
insight and and balance to the board and
um I know on local school boards the
students uh that serve offer a good
perspective and are very important on
school boards and um so I'm offering
this
Miler okay represent cordelli thank you
um the first problem I I see with the
amendment is that uh you would have a
student uh who is on a local school
board as a non- voting member now being
on the State Board of Education as a
voting member as a as a non voting non
voting uh the way I read it is a student
who's serving on Public School Board as
a non-voting member shall be
selected I I take it to read there onest
that's right on a local school board as
a non- voting member yeah that's the way
it further discussion represent
Damon um in response to representative
cordell's remark so if the amendment
were adjusted to specify that the
student was non- Voting would that be
acceptable that was just my
first but the answer to the question
acceptable the amendment still would not
be
acceptable represent Bel thank you Mr
shair and to follow up on that that same
line from rep cordelli um if it is a
voting member that would seem to be a
problem to me but if it's not a voting
member then we actually only have we're
going from Seven votes to 10 votes which
is an even number which puts us in a
position to have stalemates coming out
of
this further discussion represent
dry thank you so I'm I'm curious as to
why I changed it from governor and
councel shall point point to governor
Council why I change that um because
that's I'm sorry that that's the way it
should it should be stated rather than
the governor and executive Council shall
appoint um it should be with the consent
consent further discussion representa
McDonald thank you Mr chair uh question
for the
representative the word current is used
as a parent who is current of a public
school student and a student who is
currently serving my question is if it's
a freear term what happens when the
student graduates or the parent their
child perhaps chooses to go to a
non-public school are they still on this
committee if they're no longer current
is it current at the time of selection
or current for the entire three years of
the term they would be fulfilling their
term of three years thank you further
discussion on the
amendment
gra gson whitcock question to the chair
uh on a memo like this if if uh and
listening to represent quell's comment
if the inclusion of a comma would
satisfy the amendment uh in terms of
that concern inion of what a comma
gramar grammatical yeah is that is that
typically done um by Os or before it
goes into to
our sometimes a comma is very important
and maybe extremely important so that
tyly done the grammatical correction
down
there but the question represent leas
I'm talking to Chairman last if you can
read that two different ways you know
due to the comma then it's not a simple
change on the part of legislative
Services okay so it would have to have
we'd have to have certainly made that
change before taking action okay can as
yes if in some other Bill if it was just
a simple grammatical change would
typically legis it's just a question for
me chairman would legis typically
correct
that yeah if it was a spelling area
Okay problem or if it was wrong tense of
a verb right maybe okay because you know
past or present or future could be
interpreted so it has to be very very
small technical correction okay thank
you appreciate it
further discussion on the
amendment I see on the amendment I still
raised the question here now you have
from one person from the New Hampshire
Association yeah we have a lot of
associations out there and um why why
was this one picked vers you know Nea or
why uh not the New Hampshire school
board s
they so I I I I still I guess my first
discussion is is appr propo to this
well further discussion on the amendment
represent
Amon thank you Mr
chair I've been reflecting on the
remarks made so far and thinking about
the experience of being on this
committee and how
routinely one or more of us from the
chair to anybody seated here ask for
input from our
members who have worked in schools and
learn from and benefit including with
great respect Mr chair you reference
your career experiences very helpfully
and usefully every day I just really
don't understand why we wouldn't
doe as member of the legislature we're
here to make
law that's not the responsibility of the
State Board of Education they're in the
executive the management side of of how
we function as a
country and they're
also
representing possibly various
associations or groups according to the
way this would be written right here and
I think we want to eliminate conflict of
interest and certainly if there's a
conflict of interest on a house bill the
person is going to have a fiscal gain
from that they have to recuse themselves
from that action um
so I guess that you know I I I think
that it's important to have a a body
such as this which can have people that
are elected coming from various
professions that's fine and that can
happen too with the State Board too be
by being appointed there we've had
people in the past that have educator
backgrounds we just don't have it maybe
right now maybe they're having they have
it from some other perspective I don't
know the background of all the people on
the state board right now I don't know
it so I can't speak to
it so I'm I'm not going to ser stand in
judgment whether they do or do not
possess understandings of how schools
state yeah represent Tanner so on our
current state school board I think we do
have members that are uh working for
groups that are lobbyist groups um so I
think that um I I think that the
administrators are so vital to whether
they're superintendents or principles or
however they're in administration are so
vital to the decisions that the State
Board of Education makes and even though
it's will be a a 10 group here we are 20
group 1010
55 uh we know how that comes out so um I
think that uh those two issues are kind
of
subis I'm not going to stand here in
Judgment of the people on the State
Board I think they're all there because
they want to have the best possible
education system in the state of New
Hampshire
period And I don't think anybody out
there's trying to represent one group or
another group they're representing
various they have certainly everybody
here at on on this table has different
perspectives and how to see an issue but
we're all here in education because we
believe that education is important
they're all there on the State Board
because they believe education is
important in the state they may not be
coming from the same perspective of
another
group well that's that's going to happen
you know we we often times have this you
know you're damned if you do damned if
you
don't and that's just part of our
democracy and that if you don't like it
that's what you have The Ballot Box
for represent Bel thank you Mr chair I
just wanted to clarify my my belief on
on this so if I were receptive generally
to the concept of uh expanding the
school board something like what's
changed here to a retired classroom
teacher instead of an currently employed
one that goes a long way towards solving
my problem with that particular position
however then we introduce a parent with
a a parent with a student currently in
school which that creates a possible
special uh special interest that is
different that could be different from
the general interest then we go on and
and we add I mean these are this is a
lobbyist organization when they come in
here they wear The Red Badge and we
would be mandating the president
presence of one of them again that
creates a conflict of interests so I
don't think I have a problem I don't
think most people in here probably don't
have a problem with the concept of
people having an educational background
on the committee but it's that perverse
incentive that is created by putting
people in positions that could have an
interest that differs from the general
will in such a way that it creates
conflict that's that's where I would see
a
problem further discussion represent
leus couple comments one is yes yes we
have an even number and yes we have 10
10 but we are not the final say it goes
to
the it goes to session we have another
whole thing and another whole vote and
it's unlik you
know and that's even set up so that
generally we don't have a
tie although occasionally we do um but
the other one is the school board is
kind of the balance to us so we have as
part of the legislative branch yes we
have most people in this room are
Educators whether they're public school
home school whatever just most people in
here are Educators and so that's sort of
the representation of the schools the
system the teacher you know Etc and so
the school board is our
counterbalance any further discussion on
the
amendment Madam clerk would you please
call the role on the amendment
Vice chairman cordelli
no
what Representative leus no whoops
no representative
Ford no Representative beler no
representative dry no representative
McDonald no representative Noble no
representative Pell no representative
quell no representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative ke yes
representative wock yes representative
Hall yes representative Bon yes
representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes and chairman
lad no 10 y 10 so we're back to the main
motion which is OTP on 1437 any further
discussion on
1437 as
OTP mam clerk when you're
ready Vice chairman
cordelli no Representative leus no
representative Ford no Representative
elure no representative dry no
representative McDonald no
representative Noble no representative
Pell no representative Coro no
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell representative Tanner yes
representative luno yes representative
Heath yes representative wock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Bon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes and chairman Le
no 10 y 10
n we have no
recommendation so um who's going to be
doing the
OTP okay and represent beler were you
doing the itl thank you very much we're
right at 12 o'clock so let's take a
break for lunch we have other bills
coming up we'll have lunch and come back
o'clock
yeah we're not going to get them down
quickly
I downstairs the a lot of
people we're gonna have to well you and
talk
go ahead with the exec session for this
afternoon our we're skipping right down
to the second to the bottom uh item on
the docket for day
1695 this is relative to the release of
student personally identifiable
information and I believe there's an
around and I Look to representa cordelli
for a
motion uh thank you uh Mr chairman i'
would like to move ought to pass on
House Bill
1695 is there a second to represent
1695 represent dry seconds that motion
represent
cordelli uh yes I'd like to um uh
introduce uh an amendment um ought to
06418 it's coming around I believe okay
the motion to is OTP on that correct is
that and represent Cordell you're
welcome to speak about your Amendment
thank you um yes this is uh an amendment
um that will was uh requested by the
Department of Education uh it basically
adds uh the last sentence online 6
through 8 um uh to make sure that uh
transfer of information between
districts and the Department of
Education um is not uh confused with the
intent of um the uh requirement to
inform
parents is there
a um any discussion from the maker of
the second represent
leus no thank you further discussion
from the
committee everybody's reading it trying
to wake up here represent
bone um yeah I have a lot of questions
about this in terms of what exactly it's
trying to do um one of the uh persons
that came up and spoke to it was talking
about the data that was being released
and referencing a particular uh a study
that keing state had done and I'm
wondering if uh the representative could
share a little more light as to why this
is needed and particularly it was it
wasn't clear what actual information is
being
shared um do do do I discuss this in the
context to the whole bill or just stick
to the
amendment well for purposes right here
stick to the amendment but also if you
show how it relates to the bill okay yes
um yes
um going back uh to the bill um you know
I I can provide the information from
furpa um if you want uh that's uh in uh
c one on lines 5 through uh 8 uh talking
about furpa um and uh furpa was uh
revised in
2011 um loosened considerably in terms
of uh the availabil availability of a
student identifiable
information and um that's why I felt
that the need to um at least notify
parents when personally identifiable
information was being released um and
that's in section two and modified in uh
the amendment that we just passed out um
yeah student excuse me schools are
Contracting um with third parties um
such as the the one that was mentioned
the Behavioral Institute at ke State um
for various services and uh in some
cases sharing uh personally identifiable
information and that is um allowable
under number of
circumstances um by uh furpa these days
and um there's not much I can I can do
about that so um I think uh um the next
best thing is to at least notify parents
when their students data is being shared
with a third
party that's the
intent represent TNA or represent Bon
did you have a
followup uh yes I guess I there's there
are already
some other uh ways that that personally
identified identifiable information are
already regulated there's the children's
internet protection act the health
insurance portability and accountability
act payment card industry data security
standard and New Hampshire State rsas
and I'll list a bunch of them here but I
guess my point is it seems to me that
there already is a lot of regulation in
how that data can be used and I believe
school districts are following those
policies um I just to follow up if I
might um I don't believe that Hippa
applies to schools um secondly um some
of those rsas that you just mentioned I
wrote so I'm I'm well aware of um the
requirements um in terms of directory
information and so forth um and I
certainly hope there're being followed
because one of the provisions in a
number of those sections of law is that
it's uh in the handbooks student
handbook um including uh copies of furpa
um but I I don't think that completely
addresses um the thirdparty release of
information and um that's why I wanted
to bring this
forward representative Tanner and then
representative cascaden thank you I I
have two questions one is does this
restrict local schools and school
districts uh from working with student
data um that was the purpose of the
amendment to make it clear that uh they
uh are allowed to uh share information
as required by Statute in in most cases
um with the Department of Education and
that was a request of the department to
make that clear my question was within
the school and the district itself I
don't think so I I don't think that's uh
uh sharing information with third
parties if it's within the school or a
school District yeah sure okay and and
my my second question is needs both
off I'm not following your question I
don't think the notification is it to
both
parents or guardians or parents or
guardians but both parents because
issue the uh primary um uh parent who is
uh responsible for the child and has
custody of the
cascad um so I I had two questions um
this additional language does it um make
furpa more
regulated or does it add more than what
requires
um
I I think it
um the parental notification is not in
for so this would be something
beyond your your mic's not oh I'm sorry
uh so yes it's it's not required under
furpa yeah yes go ahead um so when I'm
thinking about third party I'm also
thinking about um the
online progress monitoring and screening
tools that schools purchase like in the
AM web or
used to buy the Dibbles or the newer
Dibbles so is that considered a third
party because we feed student data into
that
system I'm thinking of that and what
about colleges don't they have
conversations with guidance counselers
back and forth I I think that's covered
under other areas of Statute
um uh but just um if I could refer back
to um representative Tanner's question
um under I can share this with you this
is an a student guide for relation to
furpa and there's a section under the
exception represent
Hall thank you um I would like to ask a
question so if a school district
lists on their parent square or where
wherever they list it on the website
somewhere a list of the apps that are
approved by the district is that
considered parental consent that they
on um yeah um I'm not sure
um why where the listing of an app or
anything on the website would require
parental consent no but would it count
as parental consent would it count as
they're all set the school district's
all set they they put a list out of
approved apps on their Chromebooks are
they good to go parents have been
notified since it's on their website
there's another statute that deals with
online systems
um um and I can it's 18
18965 I believe that deals with online
systems so can I follow up um so during
testimony you spoke of Grants
specifically I think you were talking
about and then Anar Banfield got up and
spoke about the app so
what she spoke about you think that was
not really what you were talking about
yeah I I don't remember the detail of
her testimony in terms of apps but um
that uh you know that would not be
something that I'm considering in this
okay so that's why it was confusion
thank you represent cascaden um thank
you just another um Clarity in my mind
so you pointed out School official is
exempt from consent requirement so I
hear reference of data being provided to
Keen I'm not really sure what data
you're talking about or what's provided
to Keen is it a program I mean I don't
know but I just wonder if it's a school
official providing that then why is
there a need for this and if not I mean
again I I don't know what what the issue
is here um there is uh a I believe the
name is beh Al Institute um part of keen
state that does provide services um to
students uh in um in schools um and it
is my understanding that um part of that
uh is sharing of confidential
information that's just one example that
I'm um I've been uh made aware of um but
I think any information like that that
is being shared with um contractor or
this Falls within the exception under
furpa um I I can find that and read it
to you
um contractors that are performing a
service for the school for instance is
one of the exceptions um providing in
student information to those uh third
parties is what is allowed under
furpa
um and that is the focus of in that in
those cases when they are providing that
in student information to a third party
um then I think the parent should be
notified that they are doing
that it's I I think um you know we talk
about parental involvement and
everything but um if um their child's
information is providing being provided
to non-school
officials um as allowed under furpa then
I think at at least they should know
about
it yes represent bbon um my question is
schools why is this necessary are
parents complaining that something's
going
on
um
a year or so ago I I did um receive s
such
information
um how widespread these contracts are in
school districts I have I have no idea
um but I think this is um uh at minimum
precautionary um and um needed so that
parents can be involved in their kids'
education and should should at least be
aware if information is being provided
sources representative Heath thank you
Mr chair um representative is this in
relation to research projects that the
doing if if uh confidential information
if confidential information is being
available and it's um allowed under one
of the exceptions to furpa
thank
you further representative
Miler so I guess I'm kind of in the dark
here thank you Mr chair what kind of
information are we talking
[Music]
about
um I think elsewhere in statute um it's
um we have what's defined as personal
identifiable
information
social security number address things
like
y
sociality that
may represent Tanner thank you um so
this is the Behavioral Institute at Keen
that that uh brought up the the problem
and they didn't bring up the problem but
the was released
aware their work for a number of school
dist okay and and what exactly is the
nature of their work for the different
school
districts
I I don't remember um specifically I
never
saw well it says behavioral Institute so
is it connected to some program that's
currently in in schools that they would
contract with this is it part of the
discipline the what is it m Mt
mtssb mtssb is it connected with that uh
I am not sure if it's connecting with
not but but again that's you know one
example I'm I'm concerned about the
broader picture um you know because
clearly it is allowed under furpa that
um there are exceptions in terms of
providing um information on students
um and this is trying to uh we we talk
about guard rails this isn't exactly a
guard rails but an information rail if
you will for parents represent
leus just making sure I understand this
does not in any way stop these things
from going on Etc it doesn't require
permission it all still happens all this
does is let the parents know that yes we
provided
information to this entity of this type
of your children is that it does not
prevent anything from going on um it
just lets parents know that it's going
on thank
you further discussion from the
committee yes represent Bon um yes um I
had reached out to a superintendent to
find out more about this and uh she had
told me that U most of the school
districts uh participate in the New
Hampshire data privacy
Consortium um and they only work with
vendors who can meet the standards for
maintaining dat data
privacy um and if vendors don't agree to
those terms the districts are advised to
seek explicit parental
consent yes that that's in statute also
under governance um
requirements
yeah further discussion from the
committee representative
Damon thank you Mr chair so just
following up on that last inquiry and
answer it's not clear to
me if we have the New Hampshire data
privacy Consortium standards and its in
statute for schools
to um align with that
it seems that like that addresses this
situation or this concern
rather
um I I think that that's more in line
that the um the agency will protect that
data um it does not say that information
cannot be shared with that um uh
institution um or vendor um this is
saying that that um the information can
be shared with those vendors if they
qualify under
furpa um it's just saying if we do
provide if they do send that information
know further discussion from the
committee yes represent Damon thank you
just one
more so if a school district informed
parents either by way of the student
hand book or by a notification at the
beginning of the
year
of their usual practices in terms of
sharing uh this information would that
be adequate or are is the bill asking
for individual notifications to every
parent
ongoing um or something in between the
um the language um is that uh if it's
information is released within 14 days
they have to notify the parent of what
information was released to Who and the
educational Ser purpose for which it is
being provided which is um in accordance
with
fura are there
additional questions or discussion from
the committee represent
leus so this is just part of that
transparency we've been trying to get
going all along right just let the
parents know what's going on is that is
that correct uh that is my
intent further if I just point out um
representative Hall I think was talking
about some online apps and so forth uh
68-a further
discussion yes
sir thank thank you very much Mr chair
so so to representative cordell's
comment that with regards to the intent
being to just make sure that parents
are knowing what's going on why isn't
that already being
covered in um paragraph C which these
two points one and two fall under and
paragraph C goes and then the paragraph
C
um what rights are May um to to make
clear parent and student rights under
furpa including C the right to provide
written consent before the school
discloses student personally identif
identifiable data from the students
education
records provided an applicable
applicable state federal law what's
what's not covered there there are
exceptions under fura
um such as I mentioned the third parties
who are acting on behalf of the school
district um those are exceptions um and
so this is trying to address the
exceptions to
consent so so followup go ahead why why
does
furpa um have those exceptions for third
party I wish I
knew so Ju Just just a just a followup
shouldn't we know though to make sure
that we're not putting some roadblock up
that breaks down maybe a very important
part of of Records transfer that affects
kids shouldn't we know uh know what I'm
not sure what what you just said I wish
we knew shouldn't we
know why why why allows has those
exceptions for third
parties uh
I I remember one of the exceptions is
that the third party is performing a
service on behalf um of the um the
district for educational purposes is one
of the exceptions so with that as an
exception to the written consent for the
release of information um this um at
least notifies the
parent okay so so
so so so could and I I I know there were
other examples concerns with respect to
social emotional learning and mtssb that
came up earlier but let's pick a pick
another one let's say um Medicaid
should parent parents clearly are aware
that that that the child is receiving
services in school the parent is
completely aware that the child is
Medicaid enrolled because they had to
consent to that and should the school
district need to Bill CMS for um for
Medicaid services Services provided by
the school Under Medicaid um would this
then prevent such um you know such an
action by the by the school district I
so further discussion we'd want to
know further discussion from anybody
here M
Ken okay Madam clerk would you please
call the
rooll this on the amendment for
1695 Vice chairman cordelli yes
represent leus yes represent Ford yes
representative beler yes representative
dry yes representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
Pell yes representative cor yellow yes
representative Miler no representative
Cornell no representative Tanner no
representative Luna no representative
Heath no representative wot no
representative Hall no representative
bon no Representative cascaden no
representative Damon no chairman lad yes
NS so we're back to the main motion
which is out to pass in
1695 without
bill not seeing any if you don't have
your mics on can you turn them off so
because I see red meaning somebody wants
to oh sorry thank you very much okay
we're good nobody wants to speak on this
so Madam clerk when you're ready please
call the RO pleas chairman cordelli yes
representative luus yes representative
Ford yes representative beler yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative Pell yes representative
corello yes representative Miler no
representative Cornell no representative
Tanner no Representative luno no
representative Heath no representative W
no representative Hall no representative
bon no Representative cascaden no
representative Damon no chairman lead
yes ten
ten is there another motion
itl represent Miler uh makes the motion
to itl in 1695 is there a
second represent luno makes the
second represent Miler would you like to
motion represent
luno sure um yeah I just think there's
there's too many things we don't know
about the problems that this um this
bill um as proposed um could cause and I
think this committee would benefit from
knowing what those those would be before
it proceeds to approve um something like
this further discussion on the bill not
seeing mam clerk would you call Ro
please represent represent Caden sorry
I'm s not I just had to um my take on
this in practice is
that I would recommend people read
school policies because this what this
bill does I absolutely agree with parent
notification absolutely there shouldn't
be anything that happens in schools
without parent notification and there
are strict laws to follow that what this
bill does is to give the public a
perception that schools are not doing
what they're supposed to be doing and
cents further
discussion not seeing any mam CLK call
the rooll vice chairman cordelli no
Representative leus no representative
Ford no representative Belcher no
representative dry no representative
McDonald no representative Noble no
representative Pell no Representative
corello no representative Miler
representative Cornell representative
yes representative luno yes
representative Heath yes representative
wock yes representative Hall yes
representative Bon yes representative
cascaden yes representative Damon yes
chairman lad no 10 y 10
days yes Mo inter
stud okay there's a motion to interim
study
1695 is there a second represent Tanner
okay we're going to caucus on this one
right now you don't want me to speak to
it
first um sure if you want to speak well
I I guess I think the reason why I inter
study this because obviously there
there's concerns about allowing parents
information Etc but as we've had the
conversation there is a lot of ambiguity
about what exactly what is it that we're
doing what's available and I just
thought that rather than lose the
concept here and having to take this to
the floor to have a debate on it that
keep it within the committee so we have
a chance to have a convers a further um
clarification of exactly what we're
talking about about here I mean we we've
had a lot of bills here in this
committee that deal with privacy and I
think we're all concerned about privacy
but I want to just make sure that we
understand the nature of what we're
talking about what is allowed what's not
allowed Etc and I think it would just
give us a little more time to have a
further conversation on thank you Mr
okay with that we will go into
caucus shouldn't take too long we'll be
right
yeah
and deal is 1695 we do have a motion on
the table of inter room
study
um is there any further discussion on
study yes represent McDonald thank you
Mr chair I have yet to speak on this
bill and just want to say that I don't
believe there's anything more that needs
to be studied and the people of New
Hampshire deserve a debate on this issue
I know I've had several constituents
reach out to me in support of this bill
I'm sure other members against this bill
and not with standing either side it
should be debated that's what we're here
to do so I would like to send this to
the floor and I hope you vote against
the interim study motion thank you
further
discussion not see anything Madam clerk
would you please call the role Vice
chairman cordelli on the recommendation
of Representative M Donald no we're
going to vote either up or down folks no
dissertations please Representative leus
no representative Ford no Representative
beler no representative dry no
representative McDonald no
representative Noble no Representative
pel no representative CYO no
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative Luna yes representative
Heath yes representative wock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Alon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad no
nayson gotcha
okay who was that uh represent B bony
will re uh write the report for
the for itl that's not minority and I'm
assuming representative cordelli will
write the memo for
OTP okay now all the other bills we have
scheduled here today we either have
amendments or we're waiting for more
information so there's nothing else that
we have an ad doet for
today and what we will do though because
the bills which are held
today can be discussed tomorrow when
we're executing further bills so they
just continue and roll over so so um the
bills which we did not take care of
today uh was first at the top was 1298
that is relative to the definition of
part-time
teachers
1312 requiring parental notification of
student health or well-being and certain
curricula by school
districts and coming down to
1458 uh relative to authorizing parents
to remove children from the English uh
language learner
program 1616 Rel to parental consent for
student participation in Medicaid to
schools
program
and I don't believe we did uh 1682
either um that's relative to the Civics
requirement so there's one two three
four five bills which we are carrying
forward are you sure 68 why do we Happ
for 1682 did we do 1682 relative to Civ
test graduation program we did that
didn't
we
1682 no I thought we did remember that
was the one where we talked about the
sat at the end of it as being the
competency
test or no that's that's not this one
though 1692 so I 1692 there we go we did
1692 we did 169 but we have not done
1682 no we held
that okay there so talked about it in y
but we did
not my dad okay so we are done for
today and see y all back here tomorrow
to deal with the uh I'm so sorry
morning